[Musique]
les un film à perdre et dont on appelle
un jour très peu d'auteurs du choc
j'avais pas envie oui là bas comme on
dit marie on non humaine on disait je
suis une comparaison flatteuse
enfin jérémy ont déjà on dit charles au
jeu
[Musique]
beauville depuis 20 ans il fait rire et
qu'elle est il derrière ce sourire
derrière ce rire dernière de ses profits
à l'école communale faisait rire merci
je vais organiser des fêtes
j'étais premier à m'inscrire j'adorais
santé de l'essentiel des chansons drôles
et sam griset côtoyer les gens rire ça
me brise est vraiment ça me mettait dans
une joie intérieure formidable
déjà quand j'avais 10 ans et d'instinct
je savais ce qu'il ferait si je n'avais
pas de la de montréjeau la technique que
j'ai aujourd'hui
mais en fait j'avais déjà des résultats
[Musique]
ça c'est mon personnage mais moi dans la
vie je ne suis pas sur le mât du tour
vous faire je suis très très timide je
fais des choses sur scène que je ne
serai pas dans la vie quoi mais je fais
quand même un peu le clown dans la ville
va faire jamais mais c'est quand
je suis chez moi avec les enfants
d'ailleurs il me pousse un peu mais
enfin je ferai un autre métier je serai
aussi comme ça mais c'est rire vous
ensemble puis je moi je fais recul de
plus de tard je fais toujours les mêmes
plaisanteries alors ça commence à
s'émousser
mais enfin je je crois que j'ai parmi
les jeunes
quelques supporters autant au nom voilà
avec ça vous avait partout une photo
avec moi
[Musique]
vous aimez être reconnu ça fait toujours
plaisir parce que les gens me regardent
en se riant toujours alors islamistes
mais maintenant ça fait déjà deux
picards 5,6 a fait 24 ans que ça dure
n'est pas ce que je fais non je vais la
rangée du bas records parce que moi je
crois qu'on peut l'utiliser dans le
final a beaucoup touché
ça sert plus à rien
[Musique]
ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap un peu
poussive mais enfin c'est pousser vous
auriez vous reste je fais ce métier par
instinct alors je n'ai pas une technique
apprise
je joue avec avec mon nez est très
fatigué mais il ya des choses que
j'aurais voulu faire mais qui sont
faites par exemple j'aurais voulu faire
à part dont le rôle du facteur dans jour
de fête de tati mais pas me chercher et
ils avaient raison me suis très bien
fait j'aurais aimé aussi faire de la
vache et le prisonnier que fernandez a
fait vous n'avez jamais été tenté de
créer un personnage justement 1
manière de tatihou de des textes de nos
jours parce que il faut être son propre
auteur son propre moto grâce à elle et
alors là on peut faire ça une fois mais
il arrive un moment où on est au bout du
rouleau on ne sait plus quoi lire ce
très très difficile nice mai 1969 au
cours du tournage de l'arbre de noël
film réalisé par terence young bourvil
version anglaise de 35 ans y chante ou
d'enfants
nous sommes comme une prostituée ou je
peux encore surprendre les gens c'est en
jouant en présentant tel ou tel
personnage en étant très drôle j'ai vu
ici ou en étant très émouvant voilà le
reste tout le monde sait que j'ai une
femme j'ai deux enfants je me sais que
je suis normand s'arrête à 10 ans voit
je vais pas me mettre à faire des
discours je me suis par ailleurs
non j'ai moi je peux pas voir une radio
les hôtes peuvent en parler on peut
après on est taxé de narcissisme
voilà un grand mot pour autant que je le
connais je les objets de la chaîne et
respect si vous êtes assez nord classée
avant la fin de l'émission se fera bien
moi ce que des jeunes aucune importance
d'ailleurs les acteurs sont des gens qui
n'ont pas tellement d'importance on voit
des courants d'air nous quand on est
passé on est passés ceux qui écrivent
crs noir sur blanc
on parlera toujours de marcel pagnol
ceux qui payent ne suis
on se souvient la mesure de leurs noirs
mais nous les acteurs quand on est passé
on est passé des accords dia chantant 50
ans on ne se le rappelle par balle au
bras du rapt s'est produit jeudi rhj a
la saveur du tas
[Musique]